as her show grapples with allegations of
a toxic workplace
just how much money is at stake i think
with
success and with money you become more
of who you are
one of the best things about hosting the
show is that i get to bring joy and
laughter to the world
but the second best thing is that i made
makes me very very rich
ellen is one of the richest women in
america she's worth 330 million dollars
you shouldn't live your life in fear of
money because you're gonna manifest that
ellen reportedly makes 50 million
dollars a year on her talk show on top
of that
there's her game show she gets paid
around 10 million a year for that
endorsement deals commercials and her
popular digital channel ellen tube
oh and ellen reportedly got 20 million
for her netflix comedy special which
turned her vast wealth
into a running joke he said well do you
think you're still relatable
he said well i mean your life has
changed so much and
i said i i know but i still think i'm
relatable
and anyway just then but two my butler
stepped into the library
warner brothers makes about 35 million
dollars a year distributing ellen's talk
show
and nbc well forbes says the network has
been selling a 30-second spot on ellen
for over fifty
thousand dollars i think that nbc is
gonna work pretty hard to keep ellen at
least
not make any decisions right now during
the pandemic unless something
a little more damning comes out i always
thought you were really funny
meanwhile comedian jay leno just joined
katie kevin ashton and other celebs
supporting ellen
leno tweeted i don't discard a 40-year
friendship on hearsay
but there's another factor in all of
this ratings
the biggest thing that could change
things is if advertisers start dropping
ellen right you saw
ellen's ratings go down last week she's
now fourth behind dr
phil live with kelly and ryan and maury
so if
ellen ratings keep going down or
advertisers start dropping out of the
show
that's when nbc might look into dropping
[Music]
her